Transcriptor: ALVARO AXEL TORRES ANASTACIO
Revisor: Alessandra Mantellini
(Aplausos)
(Música)
♪ No quiero alejarme nunca de ti ♪
♪ Estoy enamorada.
Realmente enamorada por primera vez ♪
♪ “Realmente enamorada” ♪
Hola, me llamo Dan Freeman
y estoy muy feliz de estar aquí,
en TEDxPuraVidaSalón.
Yo soy un profesor de música
y tecnología en New York University
y también en The Juilliard School,
aquí en New York City.
También soy el fundador
del Brooklyn Digital Conservatory,
que imparte clases de música digital
y yo doy clases, imparto clases
en DJ Lab, en San José, Costa Rica.
Hoy estoy mostrando este nuevo instrumento
que estoy desarrollando.
Este instrumento se llama “blinky”
y la primera canción
que escucharon se llama “Prelude 4”
y es una canción que yo escribí
para este instrumento.
Y la próxima que yo voy a tocar
es uno de Bach, es “Prelude in C minor”.
Así que esta es la versión
de Bach que he tocado en blinky.
♪ Sonido distorsionable. Debes empezar
con algo simple. Se llama onda cuadrada ♪
♪ Te mostraremos cómo uno de estos sonidos
podría incorporarse a una pieza ♪
(Música)
♪ Algo simple ♪
(Aplausos)